avec julien houde où le président du
groupe rassemblement national au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
candidat à la mairie de sens et notre
invité politique ce soit bonsoir julien
on sait merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france on l'a dit en début de
cette tranche d'information le trafic
est normal désormais est la ratp à la
sncf d'une certaine manière ça veut dire
selon vous que le gouvernement a d'une
façon déjà gagné non il n'a pas gagné
puisque la contestation perdure l
opposition à cette réforme des retraites
qui ressenti légitimement profondément
injuste continue on le voit dans toutes
les enquêtes d'opinion
les français ne veulent pas travailler
plus longtemps et vivre moins bien une
falloir que le gouvernement l'entende
que le président de la république
l'entendent également et retire ce
projet et arrête ces petits tours de
passe-passe et petite manipulation on a
vu avec le coût de la chp niveau qui
n'était qu'un âge pipeau on le voit avec
ce simulateur donc qui serait mis en
oeuvre
donc six mois après donc l'instauration
de la loi
donc tout ça évidemment est rejeté par
les français donc nous ce qu'on veut et
ce qu'ils appellent les français c'est
de la clarté c'est que le gouvernement
le président la république mettre ce
projet sur la table et pose la question
aux français par référendum qui serait
la seule manière de trancher
positivement ce sujet alors
effectivement plus de six français sur
dix 61% considèrent qu emmanuel macron
devrait pas les contestations contre
cette réforme en compte et la retirer
une opinion hausse de quatre points en
un mois c'est important de le préciser
puisque la mobilisation effectivement ne
faiblit pas ce que vous avez le
sentiment que le gouvernement est parti
pour le retirer ce projet de loi vous y
croyez vraiment non je n'y crois pas
puisque ce gouvernement n'entend rien ce
gouvernement ne voit rien et ne comprend
rien ça fait quatorze mois puisque cette
opposition finalement s'inscrit aussi
dans la contestation et dans le
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune ça fait
quatorze mois que ce gouvernement jette
de l'huile sur le feu
finalement balaye les inquiétudes les
souffrances des français d'un revers de
main et surtout les plus graves at ease
les querelles puisque c'est ce qu'il
fait il l'a fait en jetant d'un gilet
jaune contre des crs là il a jeté des
usagers des transports contre des
manifestants et des syndicalistes
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'apaisement on
a besoin de rassemblement on a besoin de
responsabilité et malheureusement c'est
pas avec ce gouvernement et ce président
la république on leur en ont
effectivement l'apaisement n'est pas au
rendez vous deux syndicalistes un agent
d'aînés 10 ans d'ornon été placé en
garde à vue dans le cadre d'une enquête
sur une coupure sauvage électricité
c'était il ya dix jours dans une
entreprise classée seveso philippe
martinez qui lie en jette de l'huile sur
le feu vous votre réaction
c'est quoi est-ce qu'il faut les
sanctionner ses agents il ya une forme
de colère légitime de colère saine pour
reprendre les mots de certaines il ya
surtout une forme de collaboration de
des leaders de la cgt avec le
gouvernement finalement qui partagent le
même projet de fracturation et de
divisions on le voit avec des
comportements totalement excessifs
illégaux avec ces coupures d'électricité
qui ne nuisent pas au gouvernement mais
concrètement qui nuisent aux français
donc la cgt est très mal placé
aujourd'hui pour défendre les intérêts à
la fois des salariés et puis des des
retraités
il faut rappeler comme que la cgt a voté
pour le chaos social
ils ont appelé à voter pour amener le
maquereau philippe martinez a demandé à
ce qu'on fasse le score le plus haut la
cgt si on peut dire cela mais la cgt
c'est rouge devant et macron derrière
donc à un moment donné moi ce que je
constate c'est qu'ils sont les obligés
des mails macron ils font le jeu du
gouvernement en pourrissant la situation
et en essayant finalement de détourner
la mobilisation sincère de ce combat qui
légitime puisque tous les français
seront perdants avec ses tréfonds julien
hohl finalement c'est la cgt qui a été
la plus déterminée la cfdt elle à
négocier c'est d'ailleurs ce que lui
reprochent un sont entre guillemets
rival
de la cgt d'ailleurs quelle est votre
réaction par rapport à ces règlements de
comptes entre amis car enfin la cgt qui
s'est introduit dans les locaux de la
deuxième
franchement ça m'intéresse par mois les
querelles entre syndicats
les petites bisbilles pour savoir
finalement qui va avoir le leadership
c'est pas très intéressants sont pas les
syndicalistes et ni les syndicats qui
tiennent aujourd'hui la concertation
sont les français sont les français qui
s'opposent massivement à cette réforme
si les syndicalistes était tout seul il
ne pourrait pas agir là ils sont
soutenus par une majorité de français
c'est pour ça que ça tient après
évidemment qu'on condamne toutes les
violences on sent qu'il ya quand même un
climat qui est extrêmement tendue qui
est extrêmement je dirais houleux mais
qui a alimenté d'une part par des nervis
par des excités de la cgt et d'autre
part dans le gouvernement par président
de la république aujourd'hui clairement
qu'elle doit prendre la forme de la
contestation il ya une nouvelle journée
de mobilisation nationale qui s'annonce
vendredi c'est la bonne solution pour
vous continuer à manifester et à faire
grève c'est toujours ça qu'il faut faire
pour faire plier le gouvernement et
l'amener au référendum que vous appelez
de vos voeux
oui alors il ya divers moyens d'action
je pense que les avocats les avocats les
petits rats de l'opéra par des
mobilisations spectaculaire médiatique
jeu font énormément et pacifiquement
pour giresse opposés à cette réforme des
retraites
mais il ya surtout un moyen dont on
parle peu puisque le droit de grève
c'est bien mais le droit de vote c'est
encore mieux c'est beaucoup plus
efficace
donc c'est de manifester son
mécontentement son opposition dans les
urnes pour les municipales les 15 et 22
mars c'est le seul moyen pertinent et
efficace et je dirais extrêmement
percutant pour faire arrêter ce
gouvernement est pour lui montrer on est
contre cette réforme et on va le faire
savoir
mais vous au rassemblement national s'il
devait vous deviez être aux affaires
demain qu'est ce que vous feriez
justement avec cette réforme des
retraites parce que beaucoup de français
une majorité d'ailleurs s'accorde à dire
qu'elle est quand même nécessaire ils ne
sont pas d'accord avec cette réforme la
du gouvernement macro mais il s'accorde
à dire qu'elle est quand même nécessaire
pour la viabilité du système vous avez
un plan précis parce que
sentiment qu'à une petite confusion
c'est très précis nous déjà on nous
disons que notre système de retraite est
viable voilà contrairement à ce que peut
dire le gouvernement il sera équilibré à
l'horizon 2035
alors le cas n'est pas la même chose
enfin en tout cas des économistes le
disent et même temps il sera ici il sera
il sera équilibré donc c'est un mensonge
de dire qu'il ya besoin de l'équilibré
puis ensuite la réforme de monsieur
macron elle coûte très cher il faut
savoir que c'est entre 50 et 80
milliards d'euros pour passer d'un
système à l'autre donc ça vient balayer
évidemment tous les arguments on va
faire des économies il ya deux choses
qui peuvent aujourd'hui assurer des
retraites décentes à tous les français
c'est booster la natalité ça le
gouvernement n'en parle pas du tout et
c'est surtout faire de l'emploi créé de
l'emploi avec du protectionnisme et du
patriotisme économique c'est ça
aujourd'hui qui nous manque dans ce
système là et qui est éludée par
gouvernement jean paul delevoye avait
fait une vague allusion lors d'une
interview à nos confrères du journal du
dimanche en évoquant l'immigration
justement comme recours puisque on avait
un problème démographique vous parlez de
la natalité ça vous fait bondir au
rassemblement national avoir recours à
cette justement immigration pour que ce
système temps d'être plus viables
ça fait bondir une majorité de français
il faut bien le dire qui ne supporte
plus l'immigration qui constate
qu'aujourd'hui avec le nombre de
chômeurs que nous avons 6 millions de
chômeurs dans notre pin nombre de
pauvres 9 millions jr ce sont d'abord
ces chômeurs là qu'il faut remettre au
travail sont ces pauvres là qu'il faut
aider c'est pas évidemment en faire
venir d'autres parce que ce que ne
disent pas les fanatiques de
l'immigration c'est que l'immense
majorité des gens que nous faisons venir
l'immense majorité des 132 mille
demandeurs d'asile l'immense majorité
des 276000 titre de séjour qui ont été
accordés en 2019
ils vont faire quoi mais ils vont
grossir les rangs des chômeurs ils vont
grossir les rangs des pauvres
donc ça va pas apporter une plus value
et surtout ça ne va rien faire pour
équilibrer notre système de retraite
on a parlé de ce climat de tension ça
s'illustre sur le terrain lors des
manifestations des violences chacun se
renvoie la balle les violences
policières notamment emmanuel macron
christophe castaner qui ont fait pas une
forme de mai
ou pas mes clients en tout cas un pelé a
peut-être plus de déontologie c'était la
bonne attitude ils ont pris conscience
peut-être du problème qu'il y avait
selon vous non je ne le pense pas ils
sont responsables de ce chaos
ils sont responsables à la fois des
mutilations parmi les gilet jaune et
sont responsables aussi des agressions
de policiers et des suicides dans la
police
ils ont alimenté les tensions ils ont
jeté donc les français les uns contre
les autres ils continuent de le faire
avec des déclarations d'ailleurs
totalement scandaleuse je me rappelle du
préfet l'allemand qui avait dit voilà je
ne suis pas de votre camp à une
manifestante donc tout ça évidemment
aliments bien sûr bien sûr il est
totalement incompétent et je dirais il
est même dangereux
il est dangereux voilà le miz de
l'intérieur et peut-être seulement
incompétents en tout cas le préfet me
semble dangereux dans les propos qui
tient qui divisent les français pour
revenir sur le sujet moi je réfute la
formulation de violences policières
il ya une violence aujourd'hui qui est
politique dont l'instrument peut-être la
police effectivement et qui s'est
dirigée contre des gilets jaunes qui
s'est dirigée contre des manifestants
mais en tout état de cause les hommes et
les femmes aujourd'hui qui portent
l'uniforme de la république doivent être
respectés ils effectuent un travail
admirable dans des conditions
éprouvantes avec des moyens insuffisants
donc il n'ya pas de violences policières
et une violence politique est
l'actualité c'est aussi emmanuel avec
mon forum de la shoah à jérusalem qui
s'est illustré ce soir ce serait créée
en 1996 avec un certain jacques chirac
une altercation avec un policier
israélien le tout en anglais vous êtes
peut-être vu ce passage veut une
réaction
bon c'est de la comédie mais c'est vrai
que c'est un bien piètre acteur il veut
nous faire une chirac mais un petit peu
pauvre le seul souci c'est qu'on le voit
dans cette séquence il ya aucune
spontanéité tout et surjouée ya aucune
sincérité d'ailleurs mêmes mâcon qui
parle très bien l'anglais d'habitude on
le voit il peut faire un discours sans
le moindre accent là il force son accent
français
donc pour rappeler évidemment
l'épisode de 96 de jacques chirac et moi
ce que je déplore et ce qui est quand
même dangereux c'est qu'en faisant ça
donc tout ça est calculé il fait un clin
d'oeil aux communautaristes en france
qui sont évidemment antisémites qui sont
hostiles à l'état d'israël
je trouve ça dangereux puisque lille en
soins et en même temps il fait cette
séquence
et puis condamne évidemment
l'antisionisme donc dans un discours
tout cela évidemment n'a aucun sens le
fait que le président français soit le
seul délit gens qui seront sur place à
se rendre dans les territoires
palestiniens à ramallah pour rencontrer
mahmoud abbas
normalement il devait le faire peut-être
ce soir en tout cas elle le fera cette
semaine c'est une bonne chose que le
président français parle à tout le monde
c'est une bonne chose
moi j'aimerais qu'il soit clair en tout
cas il faut que nous soyons les alliés
et les protecteurs d'israël israël
il faut le dire est menacé de mort un
toujours des grands des états des
terroristes aujourd'hui constitue une
menace pour pour son indépendance pour
la liberté des israéliens je pense qu'il
faut être sans ambiguïté dans ce combat
là puisque le combat que mène israël
c'est aussi notre combat et je rejoins
aussi les la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme en france voilà qui doit
être l'un des combats fondamentaux mais
la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
il faut lui donner un nom c'est surtout
la lutte contre l'islamisme ce que
refuse de faire ce président de la
république un mot on arrive à la fin de
cette interview sur les municipales
puisque vous êtes candidat à sens un
petit mot tout d'abord sur cette
circulaire castaner je rappelle aux
téléspectateurs en dessous de 9000
habitants ne sera pas forcément obligé
d'étiqueter ça veut dire que les
décomptes on sera pas s'ils sont la
république en marche ou un autre parti
il ya beaucoup de parties notamment les
républicains qui dénoncent ceux là ce
que vous en faites partie au
rassemblement national oui bien sûr on
dénonce la manipulation la magouille
de gouvernement de cette circulaire qui
vise évidemment à a réhaussé
mécaniquement mathématiquement les
scores de la république en marche dont
la sociologie électorale évidemment se
situent principalement dans les grandes
villes dans les métropoles dans les
agglomérations
c'est pour si on prends mon département
de l'yonne par exemple vous avez
seulement trois communes qui vont être
comptabilisés qu'ils sont au dessus de
9000 habitants
donc c'est à dire que toutes les autres
et notamment des petites communes où
d'ailleurs on n'aura pas forcément de
deux candidats mais avec des maires qui
aimeraient aussi être représentés
politiquement donc donc seront passés
sous silence
moi je considère que c'est un déni de
démocratie bien sûr et ça montre bien
que la république en marche a très peur
du résultat des élections municipales
ils ont déjà beaucoup de mal à faire
leur liste beaucoup de mal à trouver des
candidats il s'objecte débauché à gauche
comme à droite ils sont obligés même de
cacher leurs étiquettes quelquefois pour
pour se présenter devant les électeurs
donc s'ils montrent bien que ils sont je
dirais apeurés et j'ai gardé le tout de
même je coupe mon arrivée à la fin vous
aussi au rassemblement national vous
savez pas toujours réussi à faire le
plein vous avez eu parfois du mal à
trouver des candidats et vous avez
ouvert d'ailleurs les les sélections il
n'y a pas que l'anneau de soins on ouvre
parce que nous sommes dans une dynamique
de rassemblement mais nous nous assumons
pleinement nos couleurs nos valeurs et
nous aurons toujours le logo rassemble
nationale nous trompons pas nos
électeurs contrairement à nous à devrait
vous les avez trouvés tout va comme il a
alors abattu tout cas moi j'ai ma liste
à sens donc une liste de rassemblement
puisque à peine un tiers des membres de
la liste ont étiqueté rassure nationale
c'est une liste de rassemblement
communal donc qui cherche évidemment à a
changé de sens puisque c'est mon slogan
quel score la victoire la victoire s'est
terminé le temps où leur assemblée
nationale front national faisait de la
figuration
là nous sommes là pour gouverner nous
sommes là pour montrer ce que nous
savons faire et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde le bilan de nos mères et rennes
donc un peu partout à hénin beaumont à
fréjus à beaucaire il est excellent donc
nous pouvons le faire partout y compris
à sens merci beaucoup julien d'avoir été
avec nous en direct assure rt france